why do we want to know so much about who
Sharna likes I don't know eriously
possibly because I'm the only single
girl in the house so that just means I'm
the topic of conversation everyone's
ready to everyone's ready to marry me
off to somebody is like okay - we'll
just breathe for a second does it get on
your nerves or is it I mean do you just
take it this journey isn't about that
this show isn't about my dating life is
about Bono right here and what we're
doing out on that floor every day so you
know I want to have everyone just be so
proud and impressed and inspired by what
he did today
and I love the way you did but I'm a
single girl to struggle - so funny girl
listen Oh hundred five - Oh Dorothy want
you to find you with boy don't play
we're gonna monitor lay with me I grew
up on a farm I love a cowboy don't play
with me thank you horseback ride our own
cowboys what have horses don't play with
Miller's I monkey-talk sack for muffin I
love him oh it's happening I grab a new
chemistry I grow down the street on
goodtime country now I can line dance
with the best of them well you might be
able to teach me something
I'm falling for these blue eye
[Music]